[Music]
my name is nun Donna I'm a p.m. with
Apogee and I'm going to be talking to
you guys a bit about API management and
micro services before I introduce gallo
from HP and he's going to talk to you
guys about how HP used micro services
and API management in their
transformation so let's start off big
very quickly with you know why
enterprises are building micro services
based architectures and what's the
driving factor our two main reasons come
to my mind when enterprises are talking
about micro services the first is that
the more take advantage of cloud-based
infrastructure now we may all not agree
on what micro services are but there's
general consensus on what a micro
services stack looks like and the
general idea is that by building your
applications or workloads to be
compatible with this architecture
enables you to move these workloads to
the cloud
even if they don't move right away it
gives the companies choices to move to
the cloud the second big idea behind
micro services and we hear this all the
time is velocity speed agility and all
of this right and and the problem with
monolith applications were it took
forever to test it took forever to make
production releases and micro services
promised the an architecture where you
had the agility to make deployments
faster
so as enterprises started decomposing
their micro services into independent
units developers got the chance to
independently develop deploy version
scale those services with and these are
problems that you didn't have with micro
services so in theory we should come to
a conclusion that yes micro services are
awesome all problems were solved well it
is true that the challenges with speed
and agility were definitely solved with
a micro services architecture new
problems were introduced right when you
had all these development teams building
micro services governance became a big
issue
you like where do I do em TLS where do i
do load balancing how do I ensure that
the right telemetry is collected or
there's a performance issue every
micro-services team says yeah my service
is doing just fine and so we saw the
advent of service management tools and
so a service management tool is really
catered to the persona of a service
operator a service operator is someone
who's concerned with the fleet of
services that he or she manages and
they're interested to apply governance
across these services that governance
standard could be MPLS for all my
services I want to capture telemetry not
have every micro services team invent
these concepts for their micro services
nor have these things put into the code
base of your micro services start to
think of these capabilities as available
in the infrastructure itself
so I'm I get features like governance
observability and basic security into
each of my macro services so imagine
that you have micro services and you're
using a tool with all with it that gives
you these capabilities is it done is
there anything else that is missing well
when you think about it yes we have
solved a problem for a service operator
who's looking at these services
introduction but before services get to
production there is a set of
capabilities that we need for producers
and consumers so teams that are building
micro services are often building micro
services that are consumed by other
teams teams outside your zone of trust
those other teams could be in other
departments in your organization could
even be outside the enterprise so when
you have teams outside your enterprise
who are consuming services where do they
find your micro services how do they
know what the documentation for your
micro services looks like how do they
get access to these services and how do
you manage that
so the concept of managing the
relationship between producers and
consumers is critical to API management
so a consumer of your micro service
should go to a portal seek access to a
micro service he or she wants
access to cuz they're building other
micro services based on this and now
comes the concerns of a provider as a
provider I want to manage who can access
my micro services I want to be able to
revoke their access or grant access if I
am granting access I may want to run
different degrees of access to my micro
services I'll build a micro service once
and have different degrees of access to
internal consumers versus external
consumers so at one point yes as a
developer I other as a producer I want
to engage consumers I want to control
their access and then also control what
type of access I want to give them so
once you've defined who gets access to
my micro services and how they get
access to it the next step obviously is
to enforce that access policy
enforcement when we think of policy
enforcement we really think about a
gateway a gateway is typically placed
that where you do policy enforcement
also known as policy enforcement points
I mean you think about API gateways this
is a picture that comes to mind or
capabilities that we all expect API
gateways to have you want your api
gateways to do things like rate limiting
or spike arrests they want do you want
those gateways to verify tokens you want
the gateways to even provide other
features not related to security like
caching of requests or responses these
are all things that we come to expect of
an API gateway and when we talk about
API gateways a pattern that has served
for many years is this sort of a
centralized API gateway these fluster or
groups of API gateways often served as a
single entry point into your into your
api's api or company name com would
really be the one that's receiving the
requests which is a group of gateways
that are facade to all your API and
these gateways did functions like rate
limiting checking the token did all this
in addition to more advanced features
like aggregating a bunch of services to
give you the facade as if they were one
they also orchestrated other micro
services or service
is and they perform that function fairly
well but when you start thinking about
using this pattern for microservices
something doesn't always fit right it is
not uncommon for a single transaction
from one of your channels to a back-end
go through a number of micro services
before it goes in before it goes to the
database and as it goes through your
micro services it is onerous to have
every micro service go back to a
centralized gateway and hit the database
clearly that's not a viable option and
so to deal with this situation we now
see patterns that are citecar api
gateways sometimes they're also referred
to as micro gateways so a site car is a
process that runs in the same trust zone
as your micro service you really have to
think about it as an extension of your
application it's not something else but
is a separate process and the
application of the micro service in this
case delegate certain responsibilities
to the site guard so you don't have to
implement it yourself and a sidecar
gateway is ideal for implementing
allowed denying type of rules
what are allowed deny type of routes the
rate-limiting is one do I allow traffic
to our block it checking a token or a
key is a allow deny rule do I allow this
access or deny this and that perfect for
this sort of a scenario which is
typically what we see when you have
micro services calling other micro
services so does that mean that that's
the only pattern that fits micro
services that everything is a site card
gateway but our position is that you
don't necessarily have to choose you
could have an intelligent ingress that
is able to decide for every API should
this API be enforced by a sidecar or
should this be enforced by a more
centralized gateway and you could use
various techniques to discriminate what
type of a Gateway needs to enforce
policies on this so based on a verb a
path or something in the header you
could route traffic to a centralized
gateway to get more advanced functions
for it because that API needs it or it
could be directly routed to a Sai
card because that is all what was needed
there will be some cases which really go
through both gateways and that's
perfectly fine too
as long as you're not duplicating
functionality so the other thing to
remember as you're building micro
services is that not everything in your
enterprise is going to be a micro
service yes sure you are all in the
transition phase where you're building
applications in that but there are also
other types of applications in your
enterprise most enterprises will still
have a good set of soy-based services
that they're trying to modernize slowly
enterprises are being forced to expose a
lot of their api's to the public you
know
standards like open banking or forcing
banks to have public facing API but
things that didn't happen three four
years ago
so as an enterprise you're going to have
a combination of all these requirements
also not uncommon is for enterprises to
invoke API s-- built by other vendors
Salesforce workday these are all api's
that you want to make available it's not
really nice to have your micro services
developer get another OAuth token for
salesforce get a or token internally and
have to manage all this it would be
really nice to have some sort of token
mediation so your micro services
developer deals with one type of an
access token that gets mediated between
different types of standards so our
recommendation is that when building
micro services use a service management
tool and most service management tools
like Sto or linker D they come with a
site carve and as much as possible use
the site guard to act as your sidecar
api gateway so in the case of fist EO on
Y would be that sort of a psychotic a
gateway and for cases where you need a
more centralized gateway think about a
centralized API management platform that
is able to offer these capabilities so
Apogee has a gateway that and that gives
you capabilities for all these form
factors we have the enterprise API
gateway that we have now had for about
six or seven years and it's been running
in production with many of our customers
but we have also introduced two types of
gateways the micro gateway for
customers who have not yet adopted a
service mesh like sto and we've built
the Apogee adapter for sto for
enterprises that have started to adopt
sto for service management the key point
here is that the API management platform
becomes a central control plane through
which you can control different classes
of gateways depending on the needs of
your enterprise
so with this quick introduction I invite
Gallo now to talk about how HP use some
of these technologies at their
enterprise ok Thank You nandan ok so my
name is Gallo Jimenez I work at HP at
the office of the CTO where we are
basically building infrastructure and
core services that support our devices
and our applications I've been in HP for
more than 20 years now and you know she
has almost 15 years I've been basically
building this rooted systems so I won't
go into the numbers HP was a company
that was founded in 1939 so it's a very
company a very old company for Silicon
Valley in 2015 the company was
reinvented to focus on three areas one
is basically its computing so things
like workstations and Chromebooks the
other one is printing so we do things
from $29 printers to three million
dollar printers and the last one is 3d
manufacturing one of the important
things that we have here is that HP is
operating in 170 countries so that means
that compliance and privacy regulations
are an important aspect of everything
that we do and I'm going to basically
talk how we use the cloud and the
service meshes and practice tool to do
that
so in HP that is like three trends that
are affecting the way we do things one
is what we call one life one life is
basically the blending of our personal
and professional life so we use the same
devices for work imply
the other one is as a service so the
go-to-market is changing from a
transactional to contractual so you can
see this in IT organizations of loading
their operations to other groups so
basically they don't have to deploy
manage and secure services and the last
one is security and privacy which is
obviously with more devices connected
consumers and organizations are
basically consuming and producing very
valuable data that we need to protect
okay so these trends basically set the
direction of our organization and then
in organization that has basically two
groups that have a big saying on how we
look cloud one is IT I dig with the
change in 2015 decided not to focus
anymore on data centers and migrate
everything to the public cloud and
obviously I did relational focuses on
security and cost my group the city
office basically traditionally we focus
on things such as innovation we try to
bring best practices from the industry
into the tech communities in HP and then
because we are a neutral organization we
took on the work of doing these shared
services across all the organizations
finally my group is very focused on
privacy and security especially for
global applications because all the
markets where we are so sorry I need to
go back so this basically define our
strategy for how we do cloud I mean
there is nothing that should surprise
you here so basically we are cloud
native because we are in the public
cloud we do agile we do continuous
delivery and integration with the Bob's
and because we have these shared
services contracts are very important
for us and for us contracts are
basically api's and insulates security
and privacy as I said is a very
important role for both IT and the CD
office and finally micro services is
part of our strategy and what I'm going
to explain to you is how we do micro
service in HP my way
so why Widow microservices the real
reason is basically product velocity we
are building these applications
initially this applications where we'll
build by very large teams with many
people and this required a lot of
synchronization between those teams
these things usually in different
functional areas of the application will
have dependencies across them and
sometimes the dependencies were circular
so basically this required even more
meetings to solve those dependencies we
had this continuous integration
pipelines that will take hours and
because there were so many dependencies
there were manual gates to decide if
something was moving or not moving
forward right so at the end the result
was that features will take very long
much more longer than what all we wanted
to to put into production so with micro
services what we were looking for was to
increase the product below ceiling
so we have a smaller codebase that our
teams can handle we try to have those
small applications and services go into
production independently so they don't
have to have dependencies with other
things we have a smaller teams so the
communication in those smaller teams is
less so we have less communication is
more efficient because we can have those
smaller things usually co-located and
then because they are smaller things
they can own the whole application stack
so they can own publication is developed
coded tested move into production and
they are usually operating those
applications themselves so they are on
pager duty they get the alerts and they
own the whole thing so we call it you
build it you run it but when we started
to do micro services obviously micro
services are more complicated than
monolith applications micro services
have lots of technical problems so the
first one we found was infrastructure
cost suddenly we have all these VMs
right and these VMs became very
expensive because we have many of those
beings for every single service and
different environments for every service
we had dozens and dozens of continuous
integration pipelines right because now
you have many many
many services orchestration and
discovery becomes way more complicated
because services depend on other
services so you need to know where the
other services is in which environment
are you running are you in production
are in EPA and basically you have to
depend on the other service to be there
in order for your service to start
working there is challenges that are
traditional and normal in this duded
systems you have latest variants you
have network partitions you need to deal
with this through the transaction
sectors different services so those are
very high brands too so sometimes we
have problems with dependency versions
now you have services that depend on
other services and those other services
to have new versions continuously so how
do you know which is the other version
of the other service and when the other
team changes the version of the service
integration integration testing we can
really became really really difficult
because now when you release one of the
services you need to do the integration
testing with a bunch of other testings
other services and finally the prang
which I'm going to focus now is
basically policy a spread so this is an
example of an application with micro
services I call them a B and C and
usually you are going to have that you
have more than one version of those
services so we call them alpha beta
gamma and so on okay and these services
might be managing different types of
data some of the data is personal some
of the data is data that is not
sensitive or the single time personal
information and so on okay and your mesh
and you might think that this is a very
complete application but as soon as you
start to start to do micro services you
will find that it's very silly to get in
a complicated mess like this now you
will end up deploy in this application
in multiple data centers or cornutus
clusters whatever you deploy and your
mesh might even get more complicated so
you will have on top of a B and C and
alpha beta and gamma you are going to
have a prime and alpha prime right and
the decision of where you deploy things
in the different data centers you might
depend on cost considerations
latency considerations right so this
match is going to women to get more
messy and complicated so when you look
at the things you need to do in all of
these services you will see that you are
repeating things over and over so
basically you need to apply things such
as alpha ization identification you need
to do payload inspection you need to do
raids you need to do quarters right
I knew this usually is over and over and
over and over on every single place in
the worst case you are going to be doing
these in different languages because
those services may be implemented in
different languages some may be note
applications so maybe go to applications
or maybe Java applications so at the end
you have policy a spread all over the
place it is very difficult to understand
what is your position about policy you
don't have any miscibility about what is
going on in the system and worse it is
very easy to have a single mistake that
is going to scrub your basically is
going to bring your system to a very bad
situation so who knows is there is
things that can help to solve these
problems so one of the technologies that
helps our containers and kubernetes they
basically help us to have more density
in our deployments they saw us some of
the parameters around orchestration and
discovery
the other one is API management so now
we can have written contracts with the
consumers of our api's that we can
version and we can have visibility about
how consumers are using the API so those
different services we have API gateways
and proxies that basically allows to
centralize some of the policies as none
on this right before so we can have
things such as authorization and
authentication centralized in a single
location or payload inspection and
finally with the service mesh we can go
further and have additional network
policies implemented by the mesh so we
can have things such as traffic
encryption or basically balancing
between services and so on
okay so I'm going to focus on the last
ones so in HP we have different
applications as everybody so we have
everything from legacy to very new
applications and we have these three
different models as none describe it
about how we do these things so the
first thing is we have monolith
applications this application sometimes
they are deployed in kubernetes clusters
sometimes they are deployed in VMs right
but we still need to have this common
control plane where we want to put the
policies in this case we use this
centralized proxy that basically takes
the policies such as identification
authorization and rate limits and that's
the location where we are in the case
where we have these synchronizes or in
the case where we have envy else there
is no difference right newer
applications that we started a few years
ago we started to use the sidecar
container paradigm so basically we embed
my microwave way in front of our
services so basically our continuous
integration pipeline when you deploy one
of those services injects a sidecar
container into the pots and that sidecar
container in our case we base it on a
piggys micro gateway it's connected to
the apogee control plane so we can
manage some of the policies there now
many of the policies we cannot manage
through the control plane they need to
be embedded into the my micro value
itself so basically our continuous
integration pipeline configuration
management mechanism is making sure we
have the right policies there still this
is a little problematic because
basically the micro rate way for service
a and a microwaveable for service B
might be different right so the last
services that we are building we are
leveraging
Eastham the difference with the previous
model I show you before is now that you
have this common control plane when you
can manage a very large fleet of
microwave weights or proxies so you have
all the policies managed in a single
place so you need to have different
versions of this microwave way for the
different services you can manage this
centrally another interesting thing out
is do-it provides just not policies on
the ingress but you can have policies
also in the egress so you can control to
whom your services are talking or you
can whitelist or blacklist some services
where you don't want the traffic to go
okay so I'm going to show you a couple
of applications where we use this so
this is one of the largest applications
that we have right now it's HPV
basically HPV is the HP identity
management system so if you go to hp.com
or you have a printer that is connected
to into the cloud your identity is
managed by this system this application
right now is running in three data
centers basically we have three regions
and we have a coordinate this cluster in
every region in this case we are using
the micro graduate model you can see
this orange bubbles there that's the
microwave way that we inject in front of
the services and the traffic is sent to
the clusters through an ingress in this
case we are using nginx you will notice
that some of our pots have just the
micro gateway and the reason is we have
some back-end services that still run on
VMs they are not in this diagram and we
also proxy the traffic to those services
through microalgae so basically we apply
a consistent way of we we have a
consistent way of applying those
policies to everything that we have in
our infrastructure in this case we
decided to put the microwave way in core
natives because it's for us far easier
to scale to manage and to release than
having those microwave is deployed in
VMs with the services that are in the
button ok this is another application
this is our content management system so
most of our devices deal with content
scan or printed content and the content
goes through the cloud and this system
basically is what manages that content
so in this case the system is deployed
to data centers one in the US and one in
Europe and we are basically using these
two so what we are basically doing here
is we replace nginx by the Easter
gateway so the traffic goes into the
Easter that way and then we have envoy
injected automatically by the Easter
system in front of our services the
birthing artiste is that ability has
integrated this with their
control plane on the cloud so basically
we can have consistent identification
and authorization policies for all of
services independently of what is the
mechanism we use to deploy those
services and that's it
11 and then thank you God so obviously
we can't show you the actual systems
that HP uses but we've got a demo that
kind of shows you these these
technologies and how they kind of come
together so in this demo you know we
took have you know a simple example to
illustrate the point it's a retail
example that has a bunch of services
right the first is there's an order API
and you have a consumer that's outside
your zone of trust could be a mobile app
an online app whatever it is that's
making a request to the order API the
order API Falls the inventory micro
services are both billed as micro
services and that shows you some service
to service connectivity there with one
of these services that's exposed outside
and depending on certain conditions the
order API could also invoke in place an
order on salesforce with a partner then
and that's how they've exposed their
interface with with this order api so
what this example would look like then
actually implemented with gateways is
that you would have a common ingress
point to this application API dot retail
company comm and your order ApS are
obviously that that's the facade that
that the request comes to and then the
ingress then decides you know what to
deal with this or how to deal with this
API request now because this request is
coming from the outside you generally
would want to scan the payload to make
sure do you know the Jason's well formed
does not exceed certain capacity and you
want to do this general check because
it's coming from an untrusted Network
and that's the what you see as message
processor that's that's the name for
Apogee centralized or Enterprise API
gateway the Gateway then hands it off to
the order of micro server
all of these are running in kubernetes
at this point the order micro service
then calls the inventory micro service
but except this time it does not have to
go back to that centralized gateway even
though it's in the same cluster it now
calls the the micro gateway which is the
only facade the inventory service
exposes so there's no way to bypass the
Gateway and go directly to the inventory
service and of course there's now a call
out that the order now the order API
needs to call sales force where
obviously I don't want the order API to
code for sales forces access tokens and
all that it's already got an access
token with its and that's all it uses to
call sales force so this time in the
order API invokes this vendors API it it
calls that API without knowing what this
vendors authentication authorization
mechanism is but the centralized gateway
manages this token mediation and does
this on behalf of the order API now of
course at the end of all this we're
going to see some analytics to see how
all these ApS are being used who's using
them and so on and so forth
all right so with that let's go see the
demo demo please all right so I've got a
single kubernetes cluster on gke where
I've got my applications and micro
services installed and I'm going to use
my CLI to show you what exactly is
running let me go here so I'm going to
quickly show you the the actual micro
services so demo is the namespace I have
and this is where I've got those two
micro services I don't know if that's
beginner for you guys but if you guys
can see No okay I wish you hadn't said
that because I don't know how to
increase the font so I'll read it out
write that there are two micro services
they have the order and inventory micro
service and I know it's hard to tell but
one of them has is a part with two
containers in it one of which has the
micro gateway okay so now that we have
seen the applications that are running
will very quickly show you the the
Appaji components that are running also
on
on the same gateway this uses the
recently announced Apogee hybrid which
runs the enterprise gateway on on any
platform of your choice so this is
running now on gke so I've got all my
gateway infrastructure running in a
remote installation that's now getting
instructions from a central control
plane that's managed by Apogee so I've
got my Apogee components running it's
also got sto in it and we'll see how
they how they work together okay
so now what I'm going to do is I'm going
to try and gain access to two apart just
to kind of show you to see if I can
bypass all the security systems and
access these services so usually you
would restrict such access through
kubernetes Akal but this time just to
show you that the services are indeed
protected I'm going to get into one of
these services I've gotten access to one
of the pods and now I'm going to try and
access the service directly so I'm going
to call the inventory service from a
part that's running in kubernetes and if
everything works good I should I should
get an error message I got I get a
missing authorization because I'm even
though I'm inside the cluster I'm
running in another pod I can't access it
because there's a sidecar gateway that's
protecting all of these micro services
but if I got access to the inventory
service I should then be able to get
access to it so now if I've changed my
persona from being a service operator
who was worried about this to being a
developer of the order service who wants
to invoke the inventory service what I
would do is go to the developer portal
and now this is a quick example of the
portal that we have and I'd go look at
all the services that exist in my
catalog and now you can control access
to what micro services I should see
internal developers probably will see
most of the catalog and external
developers may not and once I have seen
the aps that I'm interested in I could
even try accessing some of these api's
from here see how they operate so for
example I'm going to take
order as an example here although I am
building the order service in this
example I'm going to assume that I want
to consume the order service I'm going
to quickly try and gain some access to
it look at how the API works
I see the response I get some
documentation about it it looks like I'm
mostly good to start building my
application based on this but there's
one important step missing I never got
access to this API and that's what I'll
do next right now of course I pre
created these but what I would do is go
to my application access and then look
at and then request access to the API is
here so here I already created a pre
created this where I've got an access to
the order application
I've got a client ID and a secret so I
can get my or tokens for it and I can
use these tokens to access my service
and this is what a typical developer
would do now assuming I've got this
client ID now I'm going to try and
access the inventory service because I
now have credentials to access that
service so this time I'm going to go
back to the same kubernetes pod but this
time I'm going to access it with a key
so now that I access it with the key I
get an HTTP 200 back I could use - we
and then you guys will see the response
it's kind of unfortunate that the the
fonts not big enough my terminal doesn't
support the changing that sorry about
that okay so now that we have kind of
protected my east-west traffic micro
service to microservice communication
let's take a quick look at how I would
protect it for traffic coming from the
outside so what I'm going to do next is
very quickly show you how that setup
looks like if you look at the containers
that I have I have the inventory
container and the micro gateway
container in the same part so the micro
gateway will scale and get upgraded each
time I deploy the the pod for inventory
okay so now let's go take an example
about trying to access a partner API so
in this case that partner API would be
Salesforce I'm not even going to try and
send a parameter to it I'll send an
empty body to show you that the partners
API is protected so I'm going to send
this empty empty string to the partner
API you'll notice two things first that
wasn't that Salesforce endpoint
I use Fazio fuzzy as the name I made up
for the retail service so I still use my
internal host name or domain name to
access this API the second it was
protected and so I got a access denied
because I didn't have the tokens to
access it now what I would again do is
go back to the portal and seek access to
the Savior like any other API in my
enterprise because I don't care what the
partner implemented so now let me let me
go grab a token so I'm going to connect
to my token endpoint and pass in the
client credentials done because that's
easy to to show and I'm gonna go get an
access token for it so now that I've
gotten this access token I'm going to
try and access the partner's API now
and that's it's that
put the
put the token in
and send in the body
all right so my order was submitted I'm
going to quickly log into Salesforce and
show you that my order got created so if
everything worked fine I had 15 orders
I'm going to do a quick refresh
hopefully there's a 16th one that just
came in and that was created through the
enterprise gateway that I just treated
now so there's a quick demo to show
three different use cases some east-west
traffic being protected not south and
some token mediation thank you
[Applause]
[Music]